Mother's Day is this Sunday,
just a reminder.
We gotta love our moms (chuckles).
You know, as an earlier Mother's Day gift,
or it's kind of an early Mother's Day gift tonight,
Andy and I thought we'd do this.
We thought we'd give our moms something
every mother loves, the sound of their children
agreeing with them.
Right, Andy?
Yeah, it's what every mom wants,
their kid to admit that they were right all along
about some advice or irrational comment they made.
Yeah, exactly.
We thought this would make moms happy.
Billy, would you start the music, please?
You're right, mom, I really should call more.
You're right mom, single-malt scotch
is not a breakfast drink.
You're right, mom, I don't exactly have an HD face.
You're right, mom, you didn't ask for me to be born.
You're right, mom, there should be more movies
where Jeff Goldblum is shirtless.
You're right, mom, they should give you back you license.
Anyone could mistake a freeway entrance ramp
for a McDonald's drive-through.
You're right, mom, we'll never really know
where Obama was born.
By the way, anyone else on the crew have one?
I do.
You're right, mom, this headset does make me look
like a teach a Zumba class.
You're right, mom, I should've learned a real instrument.
(Conan laughs)
You're right, mom, I'm basically holding down
this applause button the whole show.
You're right, mom, upgrading my thermal coil
with copper alloy should protect my heat shield
against any unforeseen power surges.
I'll try that when I get back to our planet.
Well, thanks everyone.
And now, let's hear from our whole audience.
[Audience] You're right, mom, instead of going
to a free TV taping, we should be out looking for a job.
Happy Mother's Day.
Yeah, got that done.
Nailed it.